we have a clipper yes from Grace and
Frank and what I love about and this
must be Joe well I love it is a very
funny show but it must be thrilling you
get to play Jane Fonda's friends yeah
and that's gotta be just a fun game oh
my god it was the most fun yeah great I
mean I already worked with Lily mm-hmm
it's Lily Tomlin Jane Wyman Jane Fonda
and and yeah and they're both great and
you know they were really nice because
they messed up their lines my first
scene I think to make me feel more
comfortable right no it's it's a thing
that icons do right to make you feel
better in that way maybe you'll relax
and it can go smoothly
it's smart all right on the show your
character is very funny on this show on
the show you help sell along with Jane
Fonda mm-hmm you two ladies sell sex
toys two elderly women is that vibrate
er specifically maybe you're not allowed
to say it no I can say vibrator oh yeah
I'm allowed to say it else thanks me
very uncomfortable
right but
but that's you you you you as that's
that's something that happens in in real
life it's a real profession women older
women yeah yeah we're net sell of sex
toys to older women oh okay yeah yeah no
is it I was or maybe we should do a
little research on the computer the next
time yeah yeah it should be yeah you
believe in it you think it's a good
thing I think it's a very good thing I
mean you know too bad for men but I
think it's a very good thing yeah might
be even healthy I think it is I think if
someone explained to me that it's
probably really healthy for older women
well I mean that it might have to do
with lubricating joints so you'd use the
vibrator on other
your mind it goes so fast you really get
things yeah it took me 40 minutes that's
it you don't think that's it but I don't
want to go into look if saying vibrator
made you uncomfortable then I think we
should just drop it by the way yeah yeah
yeah exactly we have a clip here and I
believe this is where you're meeting
Lilly's character for the first time
yeah right yeah let's take a look at
this clip from Grace and Frankie famous
Frank yeah yeah like I know you already
how is that weird I don't have to hide
okay let's not yes we do it's a good
thing I'm not allergic to rhinestones oh
that is a good thing shuri's cooking
dinner in your honor so it'll be the
three of us for dinner I'm making my
famous chicken pot pie it's deep fried
so you don't even taste the vegetables
oh so there aren't vegetables in it
[Applause]
you